[Music]
we've all heard that daily coveted cases
are falling nationwide now we're
learning americans are growing more
optimistic about the fight against covet
in a recent cbs news poll 47 say things
are going well a gain of 11 points from
just last month two major music
festivals coachella and stagecoach just
announced zero covert restrictions that
means no mask mandates proof of
vaccination or negative tests for entry
to put it all in perspective for us we
are joined by dr ashish
dean of brown university school of
public health good morning how are you
doing good morning i'm well thank you
all right so um let's get right right
into it uh should we be dropping the
covet 19 related restrictions mask
mandates proof of vaccinations what do
you think yeah so we're first of all in
a way better place than we were even a
month ago the infections are down about
80 across the country deaths are
starting to fall
this is a good time to look at all those
restrictions and say which ones do we
really need i think mass mandates can
definitely get lifted
vaccine mandates are going to be helpful
for the long run just keeping people
vaccinated so i think that's a good
policy to have but certainly mass
mandates restrictions on gatherings i
think they can start getting lifted both
the cdc director dr richard welinski and
president biden both say we should not
be lifting the mask mandates why do you
think they are taking that stance well i
think they're being careful and look we
always want to be careful in these
moments uh so i appreciate what they're
both saying infection numbers are still
high they're coming down but still high
deaths are still high so i think what
they're probably reacting to is let's
wait a little bit longer and i think i
understand that my take is things are so
much better and heading in the right
direction that over the next few weeks i
think it's perfectly reasonable to pull
those things that's good news yeah that
is but you know a recent cbs news poll
found that most parents believe that
kids should be required to wear their
masks
in school so how should schools be
looking at this yeah so i'm a parent and
i'm uh and i the way i look at it is if
you're in a community
with high vaccination rates infection
numbers are getting low
i think it's very reasonable to lift
mass mandates in schools it's lifting of
the mandates meaning if some parents
still want to send their kids masks if
kids want to wear a mask there's no
downside to that there's no
there's no restriction on that but i
don't know that we need to be mandating
it at this point yeah you know i was
thinking that sunday watching the super
bowl that we may look back on that super
bowl which felt very normal i didn't see
a lot of math in the stands and think
that was a milestone in the country's
turn away from the virus but what's
happening here dr jaw is a lot of people
are still emotionally they're fearful
right they hear about removing these
restrictions and their body says whoa
whoa whoa we remember how bad this was
yeah so what do you what do you say to
people who believe in the science
like you think you're an authority but
are like i'm just uncomfortable
something triggers me yeah no i totally
understand that we've had two years of a
very very difficult pandemic um that's
why i've argued for being thoughtful and
slow about this if people want to take
their time no one's saying if you want
to continue wearing a mask for a little
bit longer i think that's completely
reasonable to do the question is what
restrictions should the government be
putting on people in that context i
think lifting those restrictions really
does make sense and for for
immunocompromised parents of
immunocompromised kids
could those kids one-way mask if all the
other kids were no masks they could have
one on that'd be okay yeah i think it
would help a lot so there's very good
evidence that if you wear a high-quality
mask even if everybody around you is not
wearing a mask it protects you really
well so that's one way of course we're
getting treatments and other things for
me to compromise people that'll help as
well
break down for us uh what it means for
these children now where they've backed
off from the pfizer below five years old
which parents do in that case yeah first
of all i know a lot of parents of kids
under five were pretty disappointed by
that uh decision by the fda to just hold
i think it was the right decision look
at the end of the day we want to be
guided by evidence and the evidence for
a vaccine's five to 17 year olds
terrific the evidence just not quite in
yet for under five so what i would say
is good news infections are coming down
continue to be careful let's wait for
the good data the best data that we can
get before we make a decision we haven't
won this fight against covet but it does
seem like a small victory and a step in
the right direction where we're at right
now to even have the conversation
absolutely we're in so much better place
than where we were and the good news is
we're going to continue getting better
we're going to have more therapeutics
more vaccines i think we're in good
shape we got vaccines we got treatments
we got
immunity i mean come on let's have a
moment it's a good thing okay we are
having our moment dr jah thank you so
much thank you